how do you survive these things or try  and make them make you stronger instead  of crush you down  when i was first diagnosed with cancer  they told me it was treatable  i had surgery i was in good shape then i  went to my doctor's appointment they  told me actually no we were wrong  you're going to die in 11 months we have  to do surgery and hope for the best  i thought oh i'm gonna die then i came  to tell you and i thought  wait a minute it's not up to me to  decide my fate  my life isn't about me it's about the  service that i give to the people  around me this may be my first mature  thought in my life  as far as i'm concerned i died and came  back to life when you get sick it looks  like there's no way back  maybe i was going to die but i was going  to do whatever i had in my  power to stay alive